ça c'est là où je dors de filières en
fait j'avais dormi deux nuits dans la
voiture parce que j'avais un problème
avec ma tante et du coup à soutien m'a
envoyé une trente sacs de couchage
fabrice s'est installé ici juste en bas
du domicile de son ex compagne depuis
trois jours ils ne mangent plus une
grève de la faim pour que l'on comprenne
mieux son unique souhait voir sa fille
moi c'est une chose ça les gens
souffrent c'est énorme
à chaque fois je repars que je fais des
allers retours de besoin soit
montbéliard et qu'encore une fois me l'a
pas donnée faut que je passe par le
passé un super week-end on aurait pu
passer tous les deux à faire du vélo à
faire des activités sportives à faire
des du dessin ou n'importe quelle
activité
il faut je passe mon temps seul au
commissariat de police pour déposer
plainte quand ils veulent bien encore
prendre la place
c'est un ras-le-bol de papa comme il en
existe beaucoup en france on le comprend
vite lorsqu'on se penche sur les
nombreux messages de soutien reçus par
fabrice je vous comprends très bien je
vous souhaite de réussir dans votre
action courage ou un peu plus
directement
il n'y a pas de raison après voilà je te
souhaite en tout cas ça me touche
voilà parce que j'ai pas été dans la
même situation mais j'ai connu certaines
choses
et voilà c'est pour ça que je suis là
simplement voilà parce que moi ça s'est
arrangé mais voilà j'espère pour lui que
ça va s'arranger au maximum je suis
content parce qu'en même temps je le
fais pas pour moi et j'ai mais
j'aimerais ça palabre à ce qu'on avait
plusieurs papas air en colère je reviens
sur la justice est parfois longue et
certains parents perdent patience avant
que leurs droits ne soient reconnus
c'est un problème que connaît bien cet
avocat de montbéliard qui défend autant
l'état pas que les mamans nom des
plaintes qui peuvent être déposés
ces pertes ne sont pas suivis donc si
vous voulez pour la personne évidemment
ce sentiment de toute-puissance idée
confortée par le fait qu'à une inaction
les autorités et chez certaines
personnes
pas faire de généralités il faut qu'il y
ait soit une audition gendarmerie soit
même parfois des poursuites pénales pour
que la situation change si on avait une
réactivité plus importante des autorités
qui doivent poursuivre on n'aurait pas
ce sentiment de toute puissance
fabrice nous le précise ce qu'ils
souhaitent c'est simplement la parité
entre père aimait ce matin il a même
reçu le soutien de cette maman qui
luttent elles aussi depuis de longues
années pour voir ses enfants grandir